the New York Times itself is a race
hustling organization so listen to the
way they frame this story this is from
The New York Times
about 10 percent of offers to New York
City's most elite public high schools
went to Black and Latino students this
year education officials announced on
Thursday in a school system where they
make up more than two-thirds of the
overall student population of the
overall of the student population
overall okay so now if you read that and
this is what lefties do with most things
the average person reads that and they
go my God two-thirds of the students are
somehow black or brown but only 10 got
in that must be racism this is what uh
Sunny Hosten and many other people would
call systemic racism there must be some
thing within the system some bug in the
system that is stopping black people
from getting into these high schools and
it must be that the principals are
racist there's a racist policy they're
looking at people's skin color and
they're saying we don't want black
people here well Wesley Yang who's
actually a great journalist he uh looked
at that headline and did some digging
and we confirmed this everybody took the
exact same test that was the sole
Criterion for admissions 64 were Asian
and this gets to the Crux of it
when you say you are for Equity meaning
we want everyone to end up in the same
place which is a communist idea it
sounds good for a moment oh it would be
nice everybody will end up in the exact
same place but then to eliminate what
you perceive as racism in this case
against black people you must be racist
against other people and usually these
days it's not white people it's actually
Asian people so Asian people and we can
discuss all the reasons why right it's
somewhat controversial but Asian people
who by and large focus on family and
education tiger mom right all of that
stuff they generally speaking work very
hard it's a cultural thing okay they are
scoring very high on these tests which
as Wesley pointed out was the sole
Criterion to get into these Elite high
schools so if you are for Equity as
Sunny Hostin is if she looks at this and
says this is racist what she is saying
is we should take certain students based
on skin color who score worse in these
things for whatever reason we should put
them in these schools and then in the
first version of that would be like
people would be like oh that's really
great we're helping people who need help
but of course the second version of it
the next the second order of things is
oh I'm going to have to punish a young
Asian kid who worked very hard to do
that now as you guys know this is
exactly what they're doing at Harvard
right now they are still doing it at
Harvard Harvard felt they had too many
Asians I don't even know what that means
they had too many Asians this is crazy
this is what they used to do with Jews
decades ago
we have too many Jews we have too many
Asians we don't like that they're
scoring well uh they seem to do the work
that we ask them to do and they go off
and they succeed in life but we're not
really interested in that we have this
new woke ideology here and then
ultimately of course as you guys know
what you do is if you say to a certain
kid you're going to get into a elite
high school with lesser grades you're
going to get into an elite college with
lesser grades you're going to get into
an elite med school or grad school with
the job that you want with lesser
qualifications eventually our planes
will fall out of the sky and our heart
doctors will not know how to perform
surgery
etc etc and then you will have actual
racists because there will be people who
will not want black Pilots or heart
doctors because they're going to want to
know what the pedigree was to get them
that far that is where this is all going
foreign